plus de légèreté pour clore ce journal
avec notre série spéciale Irlande qui se
poursuit à trois mois et demi de
l'arrivée du 15 du Trèfle à Tours son
camp de base pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby les supporters irlandais sont-ils
incollables sur la destination de leur
équipe Florent Clavel et Caroline de
VOST se sont rendus sur place pour les
interroger surtout et vous allez voir
qu'il y a encore du travail à faire
[Musique]
je trouve dans hungry Street c'est l'une
des rues commerçantes les plus
fréquentées de Dublin derrière moi le
Spar c'est une oeuvre d'art l'un des
emblèmes de Dublin je me demandais au
dublinois s'ils savent placer notre
ville tours
sur la carte
[Musique]
du know destin
have about Loire Valley cassos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le verdict est donc assez clair très peu
de monde très peu de dublinois
connaissent tout un peu plus les
châteaux de la Loire ça devrait changer
avec les venus de l'équipe d'Irlande
chez nous un sacré coup de pub pour la
ville en tout cas on l'espère